we have actually the scary story don't
we know now wouldn't know that we're not
gonna do this one we'll just jump over
yeah here we go here we go
this story is freaky dude Pacific Ocean
is so acidic that it's dissolving
Dungeness crab shells okay so hold on
that is scary that's man that's so wait
wait let's let's let's let's let's slow
down this one the ocean is so acidic
it's dissolving crabs shells their
shells are what I hard keratin their
fingernails yeah
melting in the ocean that's crazy you
know why this is really crazy though
what I saw the story and I'm kind of
like oh whatever man like I don't know
what does this mean what does it mean is
it mean it's easier to eat crab nah
check this out jump over the jump over
the next story for context this stories
from 2014 what why are millions of
starfish melting it's a virus okay yes I
was just reading it so yes the virus
there a virus is the culprit behind a
gruesome wasting disease that has struck
sea stars along the west coast of Canada
in the US so I don't want to show this
an act like the same thing right but you
literally have another story only a few
years later of the ocean just becoming
so screwed up
crabs are dissolving but I said it's
crazy that's gross
it is a little I suppose we should read
the crab story though and see what's
going on these from CNN let's see yeah
Pacific Ocean is becoming more acidic
and the cash crabs that live in its
coastal waters are some of its first
inhabitants to feel its effects the
Dungeness crab is a vital commercial
fisheries in pacific north northwest but
the lower ph levels in its habitat are
dissolving parts of its shell and
damaging its sensory organs that's
creepy though that's sad they're gonna
you know they're gonna say right you
know you know the articles gonna say
what its gonna get to the point where
close how dare you you've stolen my
childhood the crab is saying you've
stole my childhood or my life yeah
that's that's what their injuries you
want to bait up yeah sure their injuries
could impact coastal economics and
forbode the obstacles in changing see
and while the results aren't unexpected
the study author the study's authors
said the damage to the crabs is
premature the acidity wasn't predicted
to damage the crabs this quickly that's
the way we knew is gonna happen
yeah what what what's what's acidifying
the oceans though whoa what was that no
clue I think the cat just like caused
damage in the house otherwise someone
broke in and they're gonna come kill us
if the crabs are affected already we
really need to make sure we pay more
much more attention to the various
components of the food chain before it's
too late
said study leader Nina been arsenic the
senior scientist with the Southern
California coastal water research
project I had to read that last name
because I can normally never pronounce
names you did I know that's why I jumped
in I'm like oh I can read this one this
is one I'm not gonna get wrong I get
them wrong all the time I would have got
there let's see I can't say no the ocean
certifies to see the ocean is acidifying
because it's absorbing more carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere which leaves
which lowers the pH levels in the water
okay so there's just more co2 in there
and that's absorbing it really hmm
that's weird
what were you expecting I don't know I
don't know dumping mercury and flushing
our toilets ocean acidification well
hold on you're shaking it
so you're saying humans didn't do it or
they did do it we did Oh
we're killing everybody a problem yeah
the world's gonna end
probably so I should I should I stock up
on cans of Chef Boyardee yeah
Chef Boyardee yeah that'll that'll no
I'm serious like I came here what
happened but when I went to the store
and I bought like a bunch of Chef
Boyardee mm-hmm I don't know why I was
like this is a canned food apparently
it's all expired already because like
doesn't last long at all gross like that
was like the worst prepping I've ever
done I was like canned food right canned
food Chef Boyardee but it was I just saw
it and I was like you know when I was
little I loved this stuff have you tried
did you try it
it was gross I'm sure they're appalling
why did I like this when I was a little
man anyway okay let's get Bette let's
get serious for a second let me let me
pick it up okay so ocean acidification
changes the coasts releasing
this nutrient that can create algal
blooms ooh that's scary dude I got some
algebra loom stories for you guys
increasing sea temperatures and salinity
according to NOAA but for crustaceans
and coral that rely on carbonate ions I
don't know that is which are less
abundant in more acidic waters to build
their shells and their coral skeletons
it becomes more difficult to build
strong shells it's not just crabs either
oysters clams and plankton all rely on
the same carbonate ions to strengthen
themselves in humans and sea creatures
alike rely on them some for food others
for economic security all right you know
I really don't care about the life of a
crab but I'm gonna tell you a story
because you brought up something before
the show that was really interesting
about these desalinization mm-hmm right
oh yeah so yeah I guess they're starting
to just pull water from the ocean take
the salt out to make drinking water but
then they're dumping it right back into
the water yeah they really they put the
brine back just the brian back into the
water it's just like so when we worked
when we were getting set up you are like
I think what if that's it right what if
it's the brine well I mean I'm I'm
thinking that definitely it could
contribute to the ocean getting messed
up and you were correct so basically
that happens so then I was like you know
so Adam brought that up and I'm like
it's a good point I actually did a mini
series like a mini mini series like a
youtube series I did like three or four
videos okay where we went to
desalinization plants and yeah so here's
this is crazy
oh you went to the plant we went to the
plants it's crazy like a whole bunch of
PVC pipes where the water just gets
forced through or ridiculous amount of
filters and purified water comes out and
all the salt flushed right back into the
ocean now this is messed up yeah so this
is in California go figure
they have no idea what they're doing and
so what happened is yes during the
drought they were panicking and saying
what can we do so I think they
reactivate an old desalination
desalinization plant thinking we'll make
fresh water for all of our residents
with ocean water when you put the brine
back in it's denser and it goes to the
bottom and and slides down the ocean
floor purging the the the lowest form of
the lowest life lives on the food chain
anything that lives along so basically
what we were being told by environmental
organizations was that
you have fish mm-hmm the fish eats the
you know the bugs the bugs eat the the
little mites and back tears and
Plankton's on the ocean floor right the
brine kills all that the bugs die the
fish die and then you create a big dead
pocket of salty water yep I don't
understand how that's illegal dumping
the brine back in well I mean here's
what are they supposed to do with it you
know the other problem is dude listen
water from the ocean but here's here's
the other the other problem is like
there's gonna come a point and this is
scary where there are so many humans
that water like you will you there'll be
water wars it's already kind of
happening in any other right now totally
yep it's pretty intense so they think
desalinization is gonna be the key right
then we're literally gonna slowly drain
ocean water and I know there's a lot
yeah
but then we're gonna be replacing with
brine and even if you pull the brine out
and dump it somewhere else yeah there's
only like there's only there's a finite
amount of people that can exist full of
more bags of water man you know so the
ocean levels will go down and once the
ocean collapse happen you know happens
like we're gone yeah once the ocean dies
we're we're dead humans are in trouble
man yeah they really are and so that's
what you don't really bought what
bothers me about these environmental
lists because is this you know it story
I really love and I love I'm saying love
sarcastically so you know the green New
Deal the environmentalists Daewon
high-speed Rail trains right so that
planes consume too much energy and
carbon emissions but high-speed rail can
be done much more efficiently right well
I don't know well it's more efficient
than flying right okay so in the UK they
say okay we're gonna do it
guess what happened environmentalists
block the construction saying no you
can't tear down the trees so what do we
do do we just like not have kids then
live in caves don't eat turn the lights
off we got this big bright lights for
this studio said yeah I don't know it's
it's a pickle we're really in a you know
you know what the scary thing to me that
was about like the environmentalist
stuff is basically people like you know
when Greta tune Berg says we don't want
to wait till 2050 20 30 or even 20 21 we
want fossil fuels ended today that just
means the mass liked execution
poor people yeah I mean I I don't know
if she necessarily means like turned the
power off for fossil fuel she said it
straight up just she said no we won't we
won't wait we don't want to wait till
2050 mm-hmm or 2030 or even 20 21 we
want fossil fuels ended today the
government's were the governments
responded like we can do it by 2050 and
she said no the reason they said that
2050 is because you've got people who
rely on heat energy from fossil fuels to
live right food production machinery
thing everything right now relying up
men and everything but here's here so
here's the tricky part
what if well no I don't think humanity
will ever cease to exist but it's gonna
be a lot of suffering once we get to
like you know mass ecological
destruction it's gonna happen but then
so what's the solution a pre-emptive
call like Greta to Newberg would imply I
don't want to imply that no no I don't
want to be as hyperbolic as to claim
she's going around saying kill the poor
but what it's like imagine if someone
said here's how I see it imagine there's
like a bunch of bunnies sitting below a
cliff side and someone at the top is
screaming push the boulder off the edge
they're not directly saying kill the
bunnies you know I mean Oh God you push
that Boulder off the edge those money's
gonna die so red 2 and Burke is saying
you know this Boulder is bad for our
village in our home and it's gonna cause
problems for this planet we need to push
it off the cliff and there's people
sitting down there so is she saying kill
the people no but what she's asking for
will kill people and a lot of them hmm
but that's whether she realizes it or
not kind of the point like if we're
going to prevent mass ecological
disaster which could result in massive
loss of life so they see it their
proposal is essentially have the loss of
life happen now it reminds me of like
you ever see the movie Kingsman yeah
with Samuel Jackson and he's like that I
think I saw the gentlemen spies maybe I
think I saw it basically they don't
remember the bad guy thinks climate
change is going to kill humans because
the earth is getting a fever to kill us
so his plan kill half of them first oh
yeah
and then he tries and the noble
gentleman spies stop him but that's
interesting but this was but no but like
yeah so Sam Jackson plays the villain
and he's like he's got a less please
like earth it's getting a fever so we
got a you know cold the masses otherwise
we will cease to exist and yet the
characters Elizabeth yeah but um I find
it fascinating because the only real
difference between what he's saying and
what like Gretta says is the intent you
know he's the villain because he knows
he has to do it right Greta's not a
villain because she doesn't know what
the result will be of her calls to end
fossil fuel production like dude farming
machinery the production of food it is
all dependent upon transporting food
back and forth there's some places like
look at man if we cut off fossil fuels
today everyone in all the researchers in
Antarctica are dead true just sorry we
got no oil to drive the ship to bring
the food or get you out get on your
rowboat and try and make it out of
Antarctica man so rowboat but but but
the crazy thing is that you know people
will try to argue while she's not
talking about no she literally said it
and then should have bunch of weird
stuff about like ending colonialism I
have no idea and it seemed to make sense
but I but I will I will say this though
like what do we do if the oceans are
acidifying crabs are melting starfish
are melting from a virus the the
fisheries are collapsing you know carbon
dioxide is acidifying the water do we
just sit back and say well you know just
let it happen what can we do about it no
I don't want to believe that I can't I
can't believe that I have to believe
that humans will eventually realize that
they're gonna die off and in our
selfishness we'll figure out the way
how does we are that selfish well I
think as long as we have you know I know
I'm dragging Greta a lot but as long as
like as Americans we do not respond to
what she's deliver and then she really
is like look I worked for Greenpeace too
you know so so early earlier on Adam
mentioned that your wife worked for
Greenpeace and yet in Sweden yelling at
people works mm-hmm in America doesn't
well you know so I was one of the
nation's best for Greenpeace and we
would go around and we would smile in a
handshake
and you want to be fun and personable
and and charismatic yeah yo what's up
dude come on I coming up here come on
come here buddy and then I walk over I
check grab that yeah you're saving the
environment not to late I got you and
they'd laugh and I'm like no escape no
escape not do it give me credit card and
they would be laughing about it yeah
you'd be falling and silly right but if
you yelled at them and some people would
try it people get mad at you they beg
don't you tell me so yeah I think we've
got we've got environmental problems you
know and I think it's made worse by the
fact that you have people in media you
have these environmental activists who
lie like the whole Amazon fires thing
that happened in the new cycle couple
look a year or so ago that
naturally-occurring thing no no no the
farmers were clearing fields for animal
production probably so there are
problems with it
mm-hmm so what happens is when when the
after they grow certain crops they burn
it off and it's like it's a normal
process okay but then you see the New
York Times all these places takes you
know satellite Heat photos or whatever
and they're like oh no the Amazon is
burning and it's like you're taking look
you know you don't really bothers me
other media does this they'll take these
things out of context and act like all
these fires are a serious catastrophe
when like they're burning on purpose you
know like they're farming I get it
cutting down the Amazon for farms is
really really bad you know but don't lie
about it right I don't know man these
people think the ends justify the means
and that lying is the only way to get
the job done or to get the clicks okay
you know what's what what what really
bugs me is it reminds me of Watchmen
have you read or seen Watchmen I saw the
movie uh at the end when you know
humanity has agreed to work together
after Ozymandias scheme mm-hmm and then
Rorschach is like I refuse never
compromised not even in the face of
Armageddon it's an interesting conundrum
do you accept the evil of Ozymandias
because it saves humanity or do you
agree with Rorschach that you can't
allow you know people to you can't allow
this deceit over the people and that the
truth must be known and so dr. Manhattan
kills Rorschach explodes
you